a new poll suggests 90% of people in the
UK want to legalize assisted dying for
those suffering from terminal illnesses
88% say it should also be available to
dementia sufferers provided they've
consented before losing their mental
capacity and I agree 100% in Britain we
talk incessantly about human rights
surely it's the basic fundamental human
right of any terminally sick person to
die at a time and place of their
choosing I've never understood why those
who are in pain and whose dignity is
long gone are expected to die a long
drawn-out death because a bunch of
medics and politicians have decided that
all life is sacred it isn't some lives
are hellish and hopeless and injured in
pain fear and despair and turn the ill
people shouldn't have to stay alive
suffering to satisfy the morality and
belief systems of others but the biggest
cruelty one Britain every fortnight goes
to Switzerland for an assisted death
because it's illegal for them to die
here at home surrounded by the people
they love we don't allow animals here to
suffer if they're dying in on pain so
why do we force humans to I'm genuinely
mixed on this one and I've got to tell
you right I absolutely cannot stand in
any way shape or form and I've seen a
lot of it suicide I just it just the
whole thing smacks with me I can't do it
right really it's one thing that you
know for the stamp it out I would I hate
suicide and this has got an edge of
suicide to it people wanting control of
a home winning that's what it's okay
right that's all right so the other
thing I was about to say was I genuinely
cannot stand seeing people suffer
unnecessarily okay so there is a fine
balance I think the thing here is decide
who makes that decision you know and I
think the decision can only be made by
the person who is actually the one
making it's all right for me so right
let's have that that's good okay because
when it comes to time for me to pull my
own plug out will I be able to do it so
the only person that can make that
decision is the person who's actually in
the position
that leads to babies that but if it
became like the countries where it is
law already what happens is it's called
a doctor assisted death and what happens
is two doctors and the judge talk to the
person who wants to end their life and
they they they talked about why they why
they wanted us to get Greg and I just
want to tell you one thing we don't sort
of say commit suicide just to clarify
that him anymore he's not a criminal now
he's taking it up that's all my mum in
the mid-80s which it was slightly and
said to me look Greg if ever I go Gaga
as she called it I want you to give me
the pills
now a decade later she gone gaga by her
standards what do you do
hmm and I'm not sure I stayed with until
she died five years later but for five
years she had a terrible life I've been
able to legally what might you have done
I would I would certainly have give
another pills if illegally I could have
done because she didn't want you to but
that she don't you ten years earlier the
trouble is the stage of which so many
people who wanted to do that could do it
actually they are in a position to make
that decision so you're talking about a
very small which I agree with you in
time the law was clear that what this
they know this suggestion is clear that
you you only do two people who have have
consented to this way before they've
lost but you know one of us leaves he
gets if I was in a car crash we don't do
anything there's a guy called Alex
Pandolfo and he's the support of this
air my death my decision campaign group
and he has dementia
and it's bits getting more advanced but
he has he's gonna go to Switzerland to
end his own life
I mean listen to this quote this this
really is upsetting he says even basic
things have become impossible now in
place of freedom and dependence I used
to enjoy my life is now full of fear and
he said if he'd waited till the six
months that were left that the law will
give you if it's passed he said she
wouldn't have been able to make that
decision and he will have to he said and
I will have to be forced to live for
years as the very antithesis of the
person I am now I covered the case of
debby Purdy when I was leaving the
correspondent and you know that was a
very she was an incredible woman
she was a woman who had a terminal
illness
it was very debilitated and degenerative
and she had gone to court to ask for the
right for her husband whom she loved her
main carer him to be allowed to assist
her in dying and that would have changed
the law and made it with a number of
safeguards legal for somebody who is
able to make an informed decision and
giving informed consent to take their
life and it was very I thought it was
very disappointing that the Supreme
Court decided not to just change it on I
agree with you we live in an age where
we expect to have more and more control
over the way we live and yet none of
that has translated into the way we die
we're not given any control over the way
we die I think it's common sense that we
have different expectations about how to
manage the end of our life now I think
my issue Carol and I do mainly agree
with you on Alzheimer's is more
complicated because when it's men it's
one with the terminal illness they've
got six months to live and you know
mentally they're able to give informed
consent I think that's one thing I think
without signers it's more complicated
because it's harder to get know inform
consent can I just read you a statement
from the Alzheimer Society this is from
Sally Copley who says any debate around
assisted dying and dementia should
reflect that everyone's experience of
dementia is unique and the voices and
views of people with dementia should be
at its heart equally important is to
take into account the specific
challenges facing people with dementia
including their capacity to make
decisions which can change over time
everyone with dementia has the right to
have their wishes respected and be
involved in their care right up to the
end of life and just you know the one
thing we haven't talked about is that
not only can a dying person not choose
how to die but the person that they love
who might want to envision this is a
lady called Sarah Griffith and who's
whose mother Julianne had a dementia she
wrote a will with her express wishes
about what she wanted to happen no
intervention do-not-resuscitate where I
can take my life when things get too
much I would do it she always used to
say to me please don't ever let me get
like this I don't want to go like this
and and I feel the same and the tragedy
of that is that this lady her mom do
liyan nursed her own father for years
with the same kind of dementia with
fasiq' dementia not which is why she
said she wanted to do not think that
that individuals decision and I say this
because I have been in a similar sort of
thing myself all right
I was on an operation in West Africa
whereby I had said to friends of mine I
take good friends of mine if you see me
getting dragged off at the end of the
day and we've lost the firefight slot me
just do me because I don't want to be
dragged off and used as an ashtray in an
African village for the next six months
and I mean and that was a decision that
but then in my back in my own mind I'm
still thinking to myself as they're
dragging me officer Johnson might miss
is there a chance I might get away
because you it's not different nine 80s
at the very end of it it's still going
to be an element of doubt in that
person's by now they want to turn that
decision over if they might get better
that there might be some way of saving
it off because you've got an inbuilt
switch which says I want to leave if you
can able to kill a colleague in the same
circumstance you make these decisions
which if if the push came to shove then
you know I think the problem is I I
certainly love the view I'd love to be
able to write down having watched my mum
go through what she did I would like to
be able to say to my children look if I
get there
help me would you do that I would write
it down but it won't help the Lord
doesn't allow that and I will then not
be in a position to do anything I
remember talking to a doctor about it
and saying I'm certain in the past they
gave people certain their answer was dr.
Shipman change the doctor ship with the
medical doctors can no longer take those
sorts of decisions but I just think the
idea put someone with the terminal
illness there is no coming back from
that there might have been a coming back
for your colleagues or you won the
battlefield but there is no coming back
from eternity and if you're if you're
scared and if you're in pain and if
there is no quality to your life and
most importantly my mind is I agree and
what happens when you're I'm saying
that's just because I feel like someone
should say even though basically I agree
with Carol I think it is really
important though and this is why people
worry about this debate that we don't
send a message that there
aren't people in that situation who want
to live that even though they're in pain
even though they might have had their
dignity stripped by their illness say
and and what the reason this is so
controversial is that groups like care
not killing which opposes assisted dying
a worried that it kind of devalues life
for those with terminally ill that they
might then feel pressured that it sends
a message that if you only have six
months to live you know you might as
well see we must listen to people watch
em here